[Applause]
[Music]
Soul grip by Panic following an
emergency alert that was sent to all
cell phones in South Korea's capital
after the attempted spy satellite
launched by its northern neighbor
I was a little confused by the alert
message this morning but I wasn't that
worried as North Korea does these sorts
of things I hope that the alert message
would have been more accurate if they
send another Alert in the future it
needs to include instructions
others criticizing the alert for being
vague
um
I understand that there may have been a
misunderstanding between authorities in
an emergency situation but it's not
right to tell people to just evacuate
without any explanation
Souls mayor defended the decision to
issue the warning
this emergency message could be seen as
an overreaction but it wasn't a mistake
will respond in a manner that could be
seen as excessive but there can be no
compromise on safety
North Korea says it plans to launch
another satellite as quickly as possible
so people in South Korea may have to get
used to more emergency warnings like
this one Mike label Al Jazeera